I actually played if I may I I don't
maybe I need your advice on this I
thought and I told myself I won't do it
and then a friend of mine said uh and
the a couple of friends and
both of them are previous guests in this
podcast so I might definitely need to do
it which is
um
you know connect
so I already have for the chess arm that
I built
um is this computer vision on the chess
board is able to to extract from vision
um
the way you do optical character
recognition extract the board so I was
gonna just build that cheating system to
demonstrate it with the reason I thought
it was interesting so something we
didn't mention is I don't know who
started this rumor but the rumor started
there it might have been like anal beads
that yeah I don't know who started this
but I do know that Elon magnified it my
username was dead center and that thing
that he retweeted which was hilarious to
me uh you're using uh what do you mean
he retweeted the clip but also the copy
pasta like the the paragraph that was
like describing the whole anal beads
Theory and dead center in the middle of
that paragraph is as Gotham chess says
and the worst part about it was I was
literally Tagged so it was as user slash
Gotham chess says so every time that
paragraph gets posted on Reddit I get
tagged
uh so it's getting posted a lot so yes
but yes he tweeted and then there's also
the funny thing which I really love the
the weirdest most entertaining thing
uh was that part of the same thing where
uh
like uh plot twist Magnus has been using
anal bees this whole time that's how he
got it yes yes I love that so much okay
but anyway uh there's a
I will I quickly realized that there is
I I have to admit that I know not much
about sex toys
and then I quickly realized that there's
a lot of sex toys that have bluetooth
capability that you can interact with
so you can it's very easy to connect
stockfish to a sex toys
actually wow actually yes so uh
apparently that's a popular thing like a
lot of sex toys
are Bluetooth enabled so you can
communicate with them so this is
actually pretty trivial to do not
trivial but but then and then in fact
there is a um
there's several libraries one of them is
really active called now this is on
GitHub friends it's in Rust but I think
there's python wrappers it's called butt
plug is the name of the library
that communicates with it supports a
bunch of different devices uh a bunch of
different like vibrators and all that
kind of stuff but then I looked at the
kind of vibrators it supports and
they're all like creepy looking I mean
like it doesn't
it it doesn't have
um I don't know it felt too dirty you
know like there's a line I was like uh
is this not gonna because the reason I
like that kind of stuff is I like the
joke of it that ultimately is somehow
educational
because to me I really care about Ai and
this is a cool little project to do it's
pretty easy to share
um
yeah but I was thinking about doing it I
was thinking about doing it at first I
said no it says kind of feels dirty but
then the the aforementioned uh friend
said no you should definitely do it
I'm sure that people will sign up right
I just went on the table like show the
vibration like like this is you're
basically converting uh now it's not I'm
not obviously a Grandmaster so you have
to say everything I feel like no you
don't
you could say the square you don't have
to say the piece the human will fill in
the Gap no a good human chess player I
can't oh that's what that's the point I
wanted to make is like for me I would
like to know the actual move I need to
make yeah so I need the full information
right so I have to convert the bishop C5
whatever to more to Morse code which is
a lot of vibration I that yes exactly uh
but it still works it's hilarious and
fun so I was thinking about doing it but
uh because it's pretty easy to do
um it would be just like a fun exercise
I love a mix of technical rigor and
humor
well this is the perfect project for
that right exactly yeah this was born I
think out of uh user comment in a twitch
stream
so I thought it was born on Reddit this
Theory but I think uh Eric Hansen was
streaming uh Chas brah and someone in
his chat made that joke and he read it
out loud that was the first time it was
read out loud
and then somebody clipped it and it
became
international news
like I don't have you followed how big
the traction got on this anal beads
thing no it was covered by every major
News Network late night talk show Trevor
Noah Stephen Colbert no international
news international news in countries
like China where I would have never
thought that they would report about
anal beads yeah did they what was the
tonality of it was it seen as a joke or
did they say there's a cheating scandal
I think too much doesn't mentioned ahob
literally anal beads like just you know
it was just accused uh accused denies uh
denies cheating with anal beads which he
never did he never denied cheating with
anal beads it was a joke internet theory
if I was him I would lean into it
yeah I can't imagine men like that's I I
don't know what the right thing for him
to do is but it's you're not touching
this one oh I I I've talked about it I
don't say the words anal beads in my
YouTube videos
yeah I'll uh okay the thing is you think
I should do the the code thing it's like
a tutorial
sure yeah I think it would be hilarious
if you find a way to do it yeah yeah you
can show that it is possible to
theoretically vibrate via Bluetooth
chess moves and if someone
shoves it up their ass what that was
another joke okay they offered you to
play naked they're gonna make you spread
your cheeks yeah I didn't understand why
naked soft problem I think there's so it
doesn't have to be naked I don't think
naked is enough